[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
émission donc face aux territoires en
direct sur tv5 monde mais également chez
nos partenaires sur ouest france.fr
nicematin.com par contre et
franceantilles.fr en léger décalage dû
aux fuseaux horaires aux antilles ce
matin à bien il est dans tous les
journaux ce matin mon invité dans le
figaro dans les échos des pleines pages
c'est olivier dussopt pts bonjour dont
jean rivet du soft merci d'avoir réservé
à notre émission vos déclarations
télévisuelle ce matin avant le conseil
des ministres qui a lieu tout à l'heure
vous êtes le ministre des comptes
publics vous êtes sur le hot seat comme
on dit en anglais en ce moment puisque
tout le monde parle de la france de ses
déficits de ces chiffres
qui va payer ces 140 milliards ça va
être un peu le thème de cette émission d
qui va les payer 140 milliards il faut
d'abord se dire ce que c'est 50
milliards c'est la réponse de la france
à la crise qu vide nous avons en 2020 et
sous l'autorité du président de la
république décidé qu'il fallait répondre
quoi qu'il en coûte à la crise du coc
vide et ne pas reproduire les erreurs
qui avaient pu être faite lors de la
dernière crise économique importante de
2010 2011 640 milliards c'est une
dépense sur trois en 2020 2021 le début
de l'année 2022 c'est le fonds
solidarité qui aident les entreprises
qui a aidé les entreprises c'est
l'activité partielle financés à 100%
pour maintenir les compétences dans les
entreprises et le niveau de revenu c'est
le remboursement des tests et du vaccin
contre le coc vie un milliard par mois
c'est 1 milliard par mois sur la route
dernière période mais c'est aussi une
stratégie médicale et sanitaire oui
quelqu'un peut conférer à cette
stratégie
stratégie de tester et de vacciner les
gens croyaient d'ailleurs mal tout le
monde à vacciner c'est marche plutôt
bien pardon mais ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la couverture vaccinale et la
prévention est d'empêcher la circulation
du virus et donc ses 140 milliards
d'euros nous avons fait un choix qui est
de les rembourser comme ne remboursons
toujours nos dettes par la croissance et
par le soutien à l'activité économique
et pas par là aux impôts nous ne voulons
pas augmenter les impôts nous avons
baissé pendant ce quinquennat de 50
milliards la moitié pour les ménages à
moitié pour les entreprises et nous
rembourserons cette dette qu'ovide par
la croissance et et par l'emploi
quand on vient vous voir à bercy on n'a
le portrait de tous vos prédécesseurs
qui sont alignés dans le couloir vous
êtes un homme de gauche on en parlera
dans cette émission bien sûr et vous
allez endossé pour paul histoires les
plus gros déficit de votre époque est ce
que ça vous fait quelque chose à vous au
fond de vous même sa place à une
responsable responsabilité le déficit le
plus important c'est l'année 2020 parce
qu'en 2020 l'activité économique
s'arrête donc les recettes fiscales de
l'état s'écroule et nous dépensons 70
milliards d'euros pour aider les
français c'est un bon investissement
c'est un déficit de 9 % c'est énorme
c'est un bon investissement parce que
ses dépenses ont permis aux entreprises
de garder leurs salariés au permis aux
entreprises de passer le cap ont permis
aux français de voir leur pouvoir
d'achat protéger et ça signifie comme
après une crise économique d'ampleur en
2020 une récession de 8% d'un déficit
important l'année 2021 est l'année de la
reprise il y à une étude qui est
extrêmement intéressante qui montre que
ce que nous avons fait s'est traduit par
une augmentation de la dette nous sommes
passés de 99 % du pib à 114 % du pib
c'est 15 points d'augmentation de la
dette en 2010 étaient 25 points donc
nous avons fait mieux si j'ose dire avec
une crise malgré tout plus puissante
mais surtout les études économiques
montrent si nous n'avions rien fait qui
ne l'oublions pas aider les entreprises
si nous n'avions pas mis cet argent sur
la table aujourd'hui la dette serait de
140% parce que l'économie se serait
écroulé et donc ça coûte moins cher de
prévenir plutôt que de guérir et c'est
ce que nous avons fait je reviens sur ce
milliard par mois dépensés pour tester
j'entendais un virologue ce matin
éminents qui disait qu'au fond on n'est
pas sûr du tout que cette stratégie
marche c'est ce que je vous disais est
ce qu'on va pouvoir la continuer de tout
le monde voilà continue tout le monde a
un avis sur tout et le propre de la
france et du débat démocratique sur ps
qu'on va sans continuer ce que je sais
qu'ils sont laissés un hiver par mme ans
que ce que je sais moi est ce que je dis
c'est que nous nous appuyons sur des
avis des scientifiques des avis médicaux
nous avons pris un soin de décision à la
fois pour retracer pouvoir tester pour
savoir qui est malade de manière à ce
que les gens puissent isoler et éviter
de donner le virus à quelqu'un d'autre
et et nous vaccinons massivement et on
va continuer nous allons continuer ce
milliard par contre ce milliard ne
dépend que d'une chose il dépend de la
vigueur d'épidémie le milliard d'euros
que vous évoquez 6 pour le mois de
décembre 28 millions de tests 28
millions de tests parce qu'il ya la
vague me bon avec des centaines de
milliers de contamination par jour et ça
continue en janvier même si nous voyons
une légère inflexion évidemment que si
la situation sanitaire s'améliore il y
aura moins de tests et c'est tant mieux
et c'est tant mieux par contre pour les
tests comme pour la vaccination cela
représente un coût mais c'est le
meilleur investissement qui soit pour la
santé des français et pour l'économie
chez olivier dussopt pts le ministre des
comptes publics qui est notre invité ce
matin en face aux territoires dans un
instant ouest france sur ce plateau
patrice millot
[Musique]
bonjour patrice moyon merci d'être avec
nous dans un appentis nous avons
interviewé ensemble olivier dussopt pts
le ministre des comptes publics notre
invité mais tout de suite françois
xavier le franc le rédacteur en chef du
restaurant ce vote patron en gros à une
question à poser à olivier dussopt pts
en écoute bonjour olivier du soft une
question sur les travaux d'utilité
collective les fameux tickets qui était
un dispositif mis en place dans les
années 80 ça roman déjà quelques années
sale cela concerne les stagiaires de la
formation professionnelle qui était à
l'époque utilisé notamment par
l'administration par la fonction
publique pour des tâches réel et qui
avait aussi accès à des formations il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui tous ces gens là
ils sont 350 milles se rendent compte
qu'ils n'ont pas cotiser pour leur
retraite et se trouve donc pénalisés
est-ce que sur ce sujet le gouvernement
peut apporter une réponse assez
française et ses français souffrent de
conditions modestes et qui ont perdu des
trimestres de cotisation et qu'ils s'en
rendent compte aujourd'hui à l'heure de
la retraite voilà depuis rennes
françois-xavier offrant la situation
était parfaitement décrite à un pont
près c'est que les 350 mille personnes
en tuque ont pour certaines cotisé
suffisamment pour valider des trimestres
de retraite et pour d'autres pas
suffisamment pourquoi cela parce que les
tuques ça a été dit cela représentait
quelques heures travaillées par semaine
parfois jusqu'à 1,8 ont parfois cela
représentait suffisamment d'heures pour
atteindre le minimum de rémunération est
assujettie à cotisations qui déclenche
la validation d'un trimestre de retraite
parfois c'est inférieur et
malheureusement aujourd'hui on a un
certain nombre que nous sommes en train
d'évaluer s'ils s'engagent sur ce
nouveau la boule de mire savons pas
encore nous nous y travaillons avec vous
river le croyez nous travaillons pour
d'abord évaluer le nombre de personnes
voire qui a travaillé sans travailler
suffisamment pour valider ces trimestres
de retraite et voir s'il ya des
possibilités de rachat qui existent le
point rassurant c'est que l'étude qui
était sur des périodes courtes ce qui
signifie qu'à l'échelle d'une terrière
ça n'a pas un impact trop massif
heureusement mais monsieur a raison
souvent cela concerne des personnes de
condition modeste qu'il faut accompagner
sa souligne un point au delà du travail
que nous menons est d'ailleurs en
réponse à des interpellations notamment
la cfdt ça souligne un point c'est le
danger qu'il y à a multiplié les
contrats aidés parce que derrière les
contrats aidés il est souvent cette
forme de précarité par un faible nombre
d'heures assujettie à cotisations
on peut trouver cette situation pour des
trucs de manière plus anciennes on a pu
parfois trouver cette situation pour des
personnes en apprentissage parce que
l'apprentissage était beaucoup moins
rémunérés qu'aujourd'hui et que le
salaire d'un apprenti ne permettaient
pas de valider des points ddd trimestre
de retraite et puis on a vu derrière
vous la une de ouest france de lundi qui
concernait donc cette affaire des tuques
patrice moyens
revenons un peu sur ce sujet a
effectivement au coeur de l'actualité
c'est celui des déficits à l'heure
personne ne conteste véritablement le
choix qui a été fait par la france et
puis par d'autres pays européens de 2,2
de consacrer 140 milliards sur depuis
trois ans pour soutenir l'économie mais
la france n'a pas été en équilibre
budgétaire depuis 1974 il y à une menace
aujourd'hui sur les taux c'est
d'ailleurs le titre du journal les échos
ce matin comment est-ce que la france
pourra faire face à une éventuelle
remontée des taux de deux manières
d'abord en soulignant l'efficacité de ce
que nous avons fait puisque je le disais
il ya un instant cette politique une
aide massive à la fois l'économie aux
français nous permet de repartir plus
vite et plus fort la france aujourd'hui
le taux de croissance en 2021 le plus
important de la zone euro et nous avons
à la fois un taux de croissance que
l'insee estime à autour de cyril 7% ce
qui n'était jamais arrivé ça se traduit
par des recettes supplémentaires plus de
20 milliards d'euros de recettes en plus
de ce que nous avions prévu à la fin de
l'année et plus de 40 milliards d'euros
par rapport au début de l'année 2000 21
c'est une bonne chose c'est ce qui
explique que le déficit pour 2021 qui
était initialement prévu à 8,2 pour cent
sera plutôt autour de 7% et donc c'est
une amélioration ça reste très élevé
mais c'est une aberration qu'il faut
souligner et autres résultats
économiques particulièrement important
nous connaissons en 2021 le taux de
chômage le moins élevé depuis 15 ans
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya de la
richesse qui est à nouveau produit dans
le pays et nous avons retrouvé le niveau
de production d'avant la crise oui mais
justement avant la crise la france avait
souhaité parmi les pays européens soit
le pays qui avait les finances publiques
et les j arrive avant la crise il s'est
passé trois ans entre l'élection d'
emmanuel macron et la survenue la crise
qu vide ce sont les trois seuls d'année
depuis plus de vingt ans pendant
lesquels la france a tenu ses
engagements européens sont les trois
seules années pendant lesquelles nous
avons ramener le déficit en dessous de
3% sur les trois années pendant
lesquelles nous avons diminué le poids
des dépenses publique par rapport au pib
diminue diminuer le poids des
prélèvements obligatoires et c'est un
acquis alors les marges de manoeuvre
elles sont les marques de mode est ce
que c'est la réforme des retraites
est-ce que je viens en marge de
manoeuvre je sens votre impatience mais
je viens comment est ce que nous allons
faire face à cela je le disais il ya un
instant notre choix économiques c'est de
pousser la croissance nous avons un plan
de relance à 100 milliards d'euros dans
un plan d'investissement pour construire
des filières compétitive parce que la
croissance économique la création
d'emplois ça génère des recettes
fiscales et sociales qui permet de faire
face au déficit par contre ça doit
s'accompagner aussi de la poursuite des
réformes vous avez évoqué la réforme la
plus symbolique qui est celle des
retraites mais il y en a d'autres nous
nous travaillons aujourd'hui à réformer
ce qu'on appelle la fonction achats de
l'état pour être plus efficaces dans nos
achats nous travaillons à réformer des
processus administratifs pour réaliser
des économies parce qu'évidemment alors
il s'agit de maîtriser la dépense
publique et donc garantir la qualité du
service il faut réforme est adressé et
bruno bruno le maire propose de
passer au crible toutes les aides
accordées aujourd'hui aux entreprises
est ce que c'est sa place
et de bonne logique nous avons des
dispositifs aujourd'hui indépendamment
de la crise nous avons des dispositifs
qui parfois peuvent se superposer qui
parfois peuvent générer les effets
d'aubaine c'est vrai pour l'aide aux
entreprises c'est vrai pour tous les
systèmes de guichet quelles que soient
les acteurs bénéficiaires dans la
société
elle reprend des politiques publiques
évaluer leur efficacité les améliorer je
prends un exemple nous avons au début de
l'année 2000 21 réformer le mode de
calcul des allocations de de l'apl de
l'allocation logement nous avons modifié
cette mode de calcul centre enlevé aucun
droit c'est à dire nous n'avons pas
baissé les appels nous n'avons pas
modifier les seuils de revenus à partir
desquels vous avez droit à ces appels
par contre nous avons fait en sorte que
ces appels soient le que le droit à la
belle soie calcule en fonction de votre
venue des deux derniers mois plutôt que
du revenu un an et demi avant c'est une
question d'efficacité et s'agit venir
aussi des économies pour les pour la
sécurité sociale donc pour l'état on
revient vous patrice noyant dans un
instant parce qu'on a une question qui a
été posée par tv 78 la chaîne des
yvelines qui est notre partenaire thiery
barbedette est avec nous sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui c'est thomas rodriguez qui a
rencontré jean michel fourgous vous
allez le voir qui est président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il y en beaucoup de chiffres un
beaucoup de nouvelles prestations c'est
quand même très floue tout ça bon écoute
monsieur le ministre il n'y a pas de
croissance sans confiance
et cette confiance
pour pour l'avoir il faut parler vrai il
faut que quand on cite des chiffres
quand on propose des nouvelles
prestations sociales
voilà qu'on comprenne comment on va la
payer et on a l'impression que et on
sait que l'argent publique n'est pas
assise sur lourdes et quand on entend
des responsables qui disent
on vous donne cette prestation mais
c'est gratuit parce que c'est l'état qui
paye ce n'est pas ce n'est plus supporté
par les français ni par les chefs
d'entreprise donc comment peut-on
améliorer cette situation pour pour
redonner confiance transparence aux
français
je ne sais pas de quoi monsieur france
parle il n'a pas cité une seule des
prestations il a dit des prestations
dans la cité aucun nom y en a beaucoup
alors patrick hoyau cette question la
confiance cette question des dépenses
valérie pécresse accuse ce quinquennat
d'avoir cramer la caisse cinquante mille
50 milles d'une diminution de 50 mille
fonctionnaires de on a on n'a rien vu
vous parlez de la présidente de la
région qui est aussi présidente
d'ile-de-france mobilité le syndicat qui
gère les transports en ile-de-france là
même qui a demandé et obtenu deux
milliards et demi d'euros des briques de
france mobilité deux milliards et demi
d'euros là même qui en 2010 et 2002 2010
à 2012 était ministre du budget dans une
période assez comparable à celle
d'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire la fin d'une crise et la
relance économique oui tu dis entre
quoi qu'il en coûte déjà noël macron par
valérie pécresse ordonné bronze le tout
ce qu'il faut où il a dit l'autre soir à
la télévision sauf les malades ou en
grèce donc elle dit qu'elle aurait
dépensé madame pécresse à un badaud vous
madame pécresse a un bilan le bilan de
madame pécresse cantat était ministre du
budget c'est le vote de la loi de
finances pour 2012 ces 15 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts essai suivi par
cinq années de croissance à 0 de baisse
du pouvoir d'achat et donc quand madame
pécresse maudit ancram la caisse alors
que c'est la même qui demande et qu'il
obtient deux milliards et demi d'euros
dead quand elle parle de l'augmentation
des impôts alors que nous avons baissé
de 50 milliards et qu' elle même les
avait augmentés de 2 15 milliards
d'euros quand elle parle de santé alors
que si lorsqu'a été mises l'enseignement
supérieur elle avait fait ce que nous
avons fait c'est d'ailleurs supprimée
numerus clausus si elle l'avait fait au
moment où il était ministre
l'enseignement supérieur nous aurions 15
mm sont plus donc elle un bilan il à son
désavantage il faut qu'elle assume mais
la défense par exemple du pouvoir
d'achat à quel coût aussi pour les
finances publiques
là les français effectivement le
gouvernement est intervenu pour que la
facture énergétique soit plus faible
mais c'est quand même 15 milliards
d'euros à partager entre l'état et d edf
alors j'ai un surcoût pour edf qui est
déjà en grande et si mutine et comment
est ce que l'état va financer et si nous
l'avions pas fait si nous n'avions pas
fait l'augmentation du tarif d'énergie
pour les français pour les ménages
français s'était pas à 5 7 à 10% c'est
50% c'est une multiplication par un
ennemi et donc nous prenons des
engagements nous prenons des décisions
pour protéger les français nous sommes
dans une situation où la reprise
économique est suffisamment forte
aujourd'hui pour nous permettre de faire
face à ses engagements et ce que vous
indiquez comme un coût des mesures sur
l'énergie ne remet pas en cause
l'objectif que nous avons pour 2022 qui
est un objectif de déficit à 100% de
manière à avoir un trajet de voir nous
étions à neuf en 2020 nous serons autour
de cette un peu plus un tout petit peu
au dessus de 7 en 2021 à 5 en 2022 et
ainsi nous retrouverons les 3% 2027
comme nous l'avons dit en avril lors de
la programmation de la présentation du
programme de stabilité olivier dussopt
pts le ministre des comptes publics est
notre invité ce matin sur tv5 monde pour
face aux territoires chaunu qui est un
collaborateur dessinateur de ouest
france qu'il connaît bien patrice moyens
à une question à vous poser sous forme
de dessin c'est une particularité de
cette émission l'écoutent
monsieur le ministre vous êtes né à
annonay et vous avez été maire de cette
ville qui fut la patrie des frères
montgolfier la question je pose est que
pour prendre de l'altitude
il faut délester mais à force de jeter
l'argent public par dessus la
montgolfière bien cette dernière ne
risque-t-elle pas de ces prôné sur cette
grosse boule piquante qui
malheureusement il n'est pas une
délicieuse châtaigne d'ardèche
il faut préciser que vous étiez élu
dardel les références sont bonnes plaise
notamment à ânonner qui était plutôt
bien bien destiné à donner et tel aviv
que vous avez été mais c'est la ville où
je suis né où j'ai grandi et j'ai eu la
chance de naître mer pendant dix ans j
habite toujours je ne suis pas retenu
par est évidemment mais j'ai toujours ma
résidence et mes amis ma famille là-bas
la question qui est posée genre
longtemps sauf que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'y répondre à deux reprises
depuis tout à l'heure non mais je
voulais la question centrale oui mais le
choix que nous avons fait aujourd'hui
est efficace et mesurables par cette
relance est mesurable par le taux de
chômage qui a baissé je le rappelle ces
mesures parce que nous avons protégé
maintenu le pouvoir d'achat des français
et aujourd'hui nous sommes capables
d'une part de tenir les engagements que
nous avons pris qui consiste à amortir
la dette revis d'ici 2040 2 c'est la
trajectoire nous tenons de revenir 3% en
2027 avec des résultats qui sont
meilleurs que ce que nous envisagions ce
qui est une bonne nouvelle et s'ils sont
meilleurs c'est parce que nous avons
moins dépensé en aide d'urgence parce
que l'économie va mieux et parce que
nous avons eu plus de recettes grâce au
retour de la croissance économique et
nous sommes capables de faire face et
sans ses engagements par contre ça veut
dire quelque chose ça veut dire que la
france a été suffisamment solides pour
apporter cette réponse à la crise et si
elle a été c'est parce que nous étions
crédible et que nous avions redresser
les comptes publics quand on sort de la
crise quand on retrouve la croissance
vous retrouvé une trajectoire soutenable
pour constituer des réserves pour être
capable de faire face à une nouvelle
crise quelles qu'elles soient la une de
ouest france patrice moyon la campagne
présidentielle s'invite au parlement
européen a bien sûr avec un discours
macro et avec des interventions a cédé
place on y reviendra évidemment heureux
députés de l'opposition qui ont conduit
olivier du soft on va y revenir je vois
que vous êtes en pointe aussi dans la
défense des manuels macron heureusement
futur candidat alors donc quand je
l'espère en tout cas et s'il dès qu'il
le sera ça sera une formidable énergie
de faire sa campagne armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
nous rejoint dans un instant merci
patrice moyon
[Musique]
mais le goff et bienvenue à 20 minutes
dans cette émission vous êtes désormais
partenaire de face aux territoires merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes détenus par
deux actionnaires ouest france et la
voix du nord dont vous êtes bien placé
pour représenter aussi les territoires
ici sur ce plateau dans un instant on en
vient à vous tout de suite c'est le
directeur éditorial de france antilles
partenaire également de cette émission
dont france antilles c'est la martinique
la guadeloupe la guyane quelles
questions vous poser on parle et on
repasse la barre des rs à mon écoute
bonjour monsieur le ministre
les chambres régionales des comptes en
outre-mer se sont penchés sur la
politique du rsa il apparaît dans
l'étude que les bénéficiaires sont bien
identifiés les gens sont inscrits dans
le dispositif
en revanche les chambres régionales note
comme elle l'appelle un échec des
politiques d'accompagnement notamment en
matière de retour à l'emploi qu'est-ce
qui pourrait être mis en oeuvre pour que
ces dispositifs soient plus efficients
qui sont extrêmement complexes et qui ne
peut pas d'avoir une réponse très simple
été très catégorique le rsa fait l'objet
des mises en oeuvre par les départements
avec des difficultés liées au
financement puisque depuis la création
du rmi et du rsa sa décentralisation au
département les compensations apportées
par l'état n'ont pas nécessairement
suivi et donc on sait qu'il y a reste à
charge important la conséquence de slam
en outre mer comme en métropole n'est
pas de différence fondamentale c'est que
les départements souvent plus consacré
de moyens au paiement de la location
plutôt qu'à la politique d'insertion
nous nous empressons de décision à la
réunion en guyane en recentralise ans le
financement du rsa pour les départements
puissent se consacrer quasi
exclusivement à la question de
l'insertion et dans la loi de finances
pour 2022 nous avons prévu d'élargir
cette expérimentation la
seine-saint-denis a été retenu et les
pyrénées-orientales sont aussi un
département candidat c'est la bonne
piste je crois pour permettre de
retrouver cet équilibre entre allocation
d'insertion avec aussi une
responsabilité mais il assume des élus
pour mener cette politique dans un
instant armelle le goff de 20 minutes
mais denis carot le directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin une
question à vous poser vous qui avez été
où vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure et
lui une petite commune en rire
bonjour olivier du soft était maire
socialiste d'ânonner pendant près de dix
ans vous avez aussi présidé
l'association des petites villes de
france depuis votre nomination est ce
que votre action a permis de resserrer
les liens avec les territoires et
particulièrement avec certains élus qui
n'était pas particulièrement favorable à
emmanuel macron ou à sa majorité je
l'espère et j'ai des contacts très
réguliers avec bon nombre d'élus ceux de
la paix vf que j'ai présidé mai mais
aussi avec d'autres je crois que ce qui
resserre les liens entre les élus et
gouvernement sont les paroles tenues et
parmi les paroles tenues par emmanuel
macron il y avait cet engagement 2010
est d'arrêter de baisser la dotation
globale de fonctionnement elle a baissé
de 11 milliards entre 2014 et 2017 c'est
un engagement tenu nous avons aussi
maintenu les dotations d'investissement
nous avons commencé la taxe d'habitation
est par ailleurs pour faire face à la
crise nous avons apporté des aides
exceptionnelles tant sur les recettes de
fonctionnement que sur les recettes
d'investissement et je crois que c'est
cela quelques temps je me déplace quand
je vais visiter telle ou telle commune
tel ou tel département j'ai fait une
soixantaine de départements cette année
les les élus le 10 et le reconnaissent
bien volontiers pour la plupart d'entre
eux ce qui est une bonne chose la une de
nice-matin rapidement avant vous
retrouvez remet le goff et bien c'est
l'arrestation qui vire au drame ne tué
par un policier hier à nice armelle le
goff et 20 minutes avec les
collectivités les aides de l'état toutes
ces questions en effet justement on
parlait des collectivités locales et des
élus qui sont au plus près des
inquiétudes de leurs concitoyens pensez
vous que les territoires les élus soient
suffisamment soutenue par l'état et
quelles sont les priorités de l'état
dans le domaine nous avons une priorité
je les dis depuis le début du
quinquennat c'est la stabilité
la stabilité c'est la stabilité la dgf
27 milliards ça ne bouge plus c'est
quelque chose de solide qui permet aux
élus d'avoir de la lisibilité c'est de
tenir les engagements et tous les élus
ont pu constater la compensation de la
taxe d'habitation s'est faite à leurs
prêts et ça se voit sur les douzièmes de
fiscalité qu'ils perçoivent dans leur
commune chaque mois c'est aussi la
stabilité des dotations d'investissement
face à la crise nous avons répondu comme
personne n'avait jamais répondu nous
avons répondu par de l'aide à
l'investissement
c'est 2,6 milliards d'euros 1 milliards
de dotations soutien à l'investissement
local
en août 2000 20 1 milliards spécialisé
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments en jean 2021 et 600 millions à
destination des régions nous avons aussi
répondu en garantissant aux communes et
aux intercommunalités aux départements
les régions étaient protégés par
ailleurs qu' en 2020 et en 2021 leurs
recettes fiscales quoi qu'il arrive ne
serait pas inférieure à la moyenne des
recettes fiscales entre 2017 et 2019
c'est un sacré filet de sécurité et nous
avons permis aux autorités
organisatrices de mobilité et syndicats
de transport d'en bénéficier aussi ses
4,2 milliards d'euros nous avons mis sur
la table pour
protéger ses recettes de fonctionnement
pour autant il ya quand même une tension
autour du pouvoir d'achat et on sait que
les élus seront plus près du
mécontentement de leurs concitoyens on
parle beaucoup de violence par exemple
qui s'exprimait à l'endroit des élus
pardonnez moi mais je ne pense pas en
tout cas je le souhaite que les
questions relatives au pouvoir d'achat
et malgré les difficultés du moment
autour de l'énergie soit une explication
de la violence que rencontrent parfois
les élus ce que je constate c'est ce que
nous constatons tous c'est que les
institutions sont moins respectée ça
n'est pas un phénomène de ce quinquennat
c'est quelque chose de long terme que
d'un certain nombre de violences qui
s'exprime et effectivement le nombre
d'élus qui ont fait l'objet de violences
aux menaces a significativement augmenté
et les services du ministère de
l'intérieur sont tous mobilisés donc
nous avons eu l'occasion de le dire le
chef du gouvernement l'a l'a martelé
sans s'en prendre à un élu parce qu'il
est élu c'est s'entendre à la république
un des symboles les plus forts de la
république celui de la démocratie locale
et de la proximité et soldates je dois
payer une réponse d'une grande sévérité
de manière générale les agressions
doivent avoir une réponse extrêmement
sévère mais quand il ya en plus une
volonté délibérée de s'en prendre un
symbole de la république un élu un
fonctionnaire un policier un gendarme un
pompier c'est encore plus inacceptable
si on peu graduelle ce qui est
inacceptable tout jour sur le rôle des
élus et des collectivités locales tarare
dans le rhône fait appel aux services de
wiki power qui est une entreprise qui
permet de mieux négocier pour tous les
habitants de la ville les prix de
l'énergie vous pensez que c'est le rôle
d'une commune de faire un malaise les
communes ont une compétence générale et
chaque mère chaque conseil municipal est
libre dans le cadre du respect de la loi
2009 avec ça les mesures non je découvre
avec votre votre question oui ça me fait
penser à patienter il ya par exemple des
communes qui mettent en place des
protections sociale complémentaire des
mutuelles à un niveau communal ou
intercommunal
dès lors que ça s'inscrive dans le
respect de la loi et les communes en
cette liberté d'action et seuls qui
peuvent juger quand c'est dans le cadre
de la loi sont leurs électeurs je
reviens à cette question du pouvoir
d'achat qui est une question très
prégnante aujourd'hui dans la société or
la hausse générale des prix selon
l'insee en décembre 2021 ses +2 8% en
francs en france métropolitaine à
effectuer nous on a des lecteurs et des
lectrices de 20 minutes notamment deux
lectrices qui habite à villejuif salia
et nadia qui explique aujourd'hui
n'acheter que l'essentiel de l'huile des
pommes de terre du sucre sinon on ne
peut pas s'en sortir qu'est-ce qu'on
répond à ces ménages ont le bon qu'on
agit non répond qu'on agit et et on
répond aussi qu'on agit avec humilité
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que nous
avons fait nous avons augmenté les
minima sociaux avant la crise le minimum
vieillesse est augmenté de presque 15%
ses 100 euros par mois c'est la même
chose pour l'allocation adulte handicapé
nous avons augmenté la prime d'activité
de 200 euros niveau du smic nous avons
modifié le régime de cotisation pour
donner du corps d'achat ils ont
défiscalisé les heures supplémentaires
nous avons revu le traitement des agents
hospitaliers notamment dans le cadre du
ségur face à la crise ils vont continuer
à agir de carrière justement j'y viens
dès le début nous avons ses premiers
skis l'a balancé annonces mises en place
à chaque énergie exceptionnelle de 100
euros pour les 5 8 millions de ménages
qui bénéficient du chèque énergie nous
avons mise en oeuvre une intimité
inflation pour 38 millions de personnes
38 millions de français qui gagnent
moins de 2000 euros net par mois les
versements sont en cours à l'heure où je
vous parle c'est 15 millions de
personnes qui ont déjà perçu c'était de
200 euros nous étions à 13 millions hier
et aujourd'hui ce sont les bénéficiaires
de des caisses d'allocations familiales
qui vont commencer à percevoir cette
aide là et nous avons pris des
dispositions s'était rappelée par votre
prédécesseur pour limiter l'augmentation
du prix du gaz électricité isselin une
fois qu'on a dit cela fera preuve
d'humilité pour une raison qui concerne
non pas ce gouvernement mais je crois
que tous les gouvernements depuis 20 ans
qui se heurte à la question du pouvoir
d'achat parce qu'on regarde différentes
études on s'aperçut que quel que soit le
niveau de revenu des ménages la part des
dépenses contraintes pré-engagées
l'immobilier les assurances soit quand
vous ne pouvez pas échapper cette part
représente un poids toujours plus
important dans le revenu des ménages je
suis tellement même lorsque les on a
parlé de possible hausse des taux même
le sur l'immobilier la rage de dire
c'est que même lorsque votre revenu
augmente et il augmente depuis
maintenant quelques années si vos
dépenses obligatoires augmentent aussi
vous avez le sentiment de perdre des
marges de manoeuvre alors vous avez
gagné du pouvoir d'achat tout à fait
alors sur la hausse des taux d'intérêt
concrètement si je doit souscrire un
prêt immobilier en 2022 est ce que mon
taux d'intérêt va être plus élevé qu'il
ne l'était ces dernières années et de
comment est ce que on peut faire en
sorte justement que les français nos
concitoyens n'ai pas le sentiment de
perdre du pouvoir d'achat nous en fait
vous rappeler que les taux immobiliers
étaient historiquement très bas s'était
fait voler les taux quand il ya un
regain d'inflation ont tendance à
augmenter un petit peu dès lors que
l'inflation et la croissance restent à
un niveau plus élevé qu'avant c'est
quelque chose qui s'absorbe si je puis
dire et qui est tout à fait gérable soit
quand il faut veiller ce qui n'est pas
de décalage entre le niveau des taux le
niveau de la croissance et un niveau
d'évolution des revenus il a un élément
rassurant et cela a été dit ce matin par
christine lagarde la présidente de la
bce c'est le fait que la banque centrale
européenne considère comme nous que ce
pic inflationniste qui s'explique par la
vigueur de la reprise économique partout
dans le monde les tensions sur le marché
l'énergie que ce pic inflationniste a
selon christine lagarde vocation à
s'estomper au milieu de l'année 2022
pour revenir dans des taux d'inflation
beaucoup plus normaux est beaucoup plus
classique
nous avons le même sentiment la même
prévision et c'est effectivement le
scénario qui serait plus rassurant c'est
un point que l'on suit avec beaucoup
d'attention pierre maille le beauf
théâtre pour qui souhaite notamment
porté la question de la lutte contre la
pauvreté sur le dans le débat public etc
des mesures concrètes aujourd'hui que
vous portez sur ce sujet est-ce que vous
pouvez en parler un peu plus peut-être
nous avons il ya deux choses dans des
bagarres ce que proposent les différents
partis la majorité le débat démocratique
la préparation d'une campagne
présidentielle telle est en progrès que
vous alliez vous hippique
je vais tout faire pour du présent arrêt
puis que soient réélus dès lors qu'il
sera candidat ça je vous le confirme et
j'ai la chance de présider une formation
politique participe à la majorité
présidentielle theater progrès qui est
au coeur de cette majorité un parti de
gauche le réaliste tu préfères l'action
à l'incantation et qui effectivement
vous sentez à l'aise avec emmanuel
macron bien de la gauche et met
évidemment évidemment et je vais vous
dire quelque chose au delà du port
d'achat j'ai été militant socialiste
pendant 20 ans je n'en ai aucun regret
au contraire une belle période de ma vie
mais pendant vingt ans on s'est dit tout
est ce que la sécurité sociale permettra
à tout le monde d'avoir des lunettes des
prothèses auditives des prothèses
dentaires sang reste à charge nous
l'avons fait quand est ce qu'il y aura
une cinquième branche pour l'autonomie
nous l'avons créé les financer alors on
sait qu emmanuel macron a pour projet
s'il était s'il était élu pour un
deuxième mandat de réformer les
retraites dans un contexte de hausse de
fin de baisse du pouvoir d'achat de
tension au tournoi donc est ce que est
ce que c'est vraiment un débat qu'on
peut pas rater avant de vous
interrogeant mai mais le même je sais
que ça se heurte à des sentiments sept
des questions des dépenses contraintes
mais lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres et
les chiffres de l'insee est un institut
qui est indépendant le pouvoir d'achat
des français a augmenté pendant ce
quinquennat de 8% et quand on le regarde
année après année il a augmenté deux
fois plus vite que la moyenne des dix
dernières années donc le prix d'achat il
voulu par contre il ya cette question
des dépenses contraintes et aujourd'hui
le retour de l'inflation la réforme des
retraites et elle est nécessaire pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que le
système est déficitaire de plus de 10
milliards d'euros à horizon 4 5 ans donc
il faut l'équilibré pour qu'il soit
durable et le système n'est ni juste ni
lisible avec 42 régime et avec des
carrières hachées en public et le privé
qui sont mal traités par le système de
retraites il faut aussi qu'on
réfléchisse aux questions de pénibilité
aux questions de durée des carrières est
donc cette réforme est nécessaire elle
est même essentiel faudra prendre le
temps de la faire et de la faire le plus
justement possible merci pour qu'olivier
du soft qui est notre invité ministre
des comptes publics et merci armelle le
goff on passe à la partie internationale
de cette émission dans un instant avec
sylvia garcia
[Musique]
bonjour sylvia garcia hier discours d'
emmanuel macron très regardé très
commenté ce matin avec aussi un débat
sur le fait que le président république
a fait du franco français là-bas au
parlement européen drôle de séquence
monsieur le ministre avec des
eurodéputés français qui sont prennent
qui rentre en campagne présidentielle
face à un président non déclaré cheikh
n'a pas plu à nous partenaires de la
france j'ai vu deux choses j'ai vu un
président de la république qui comme à
son habitude défend un idéal européen
dit que l'europe est une force pour la
france est une chance pour la france et
que la france a non seulement sa place
en europe mais essentielle même la
construction européenne et donc j'aime
aussi vision très franco-français
eurodéputés français ailleurs président
français si certains eurodéputés jean
français ont retrouvé le géant un petit
peu étonnant laissez-moi aller au bout
de la réponse j'ai aussi en tête les
propos de la présidente de la commission
qui dit combien heureuse que la france
puisse présider l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est le puits et marc tonus
menthe et puis j'ai en tête le
comportement de quelques eurodéputés du
front national ou d'europe écologie les
verts hier dans l'hémicycle qui ont
attaqué la prison de la regarder là vous
faites allusion à deux mains jadot
yannick jadot est à qui le président de
la république n'ont pas de danse à la
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne mais dans le cadre d'un débat
politicien est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai
noté c'est que la présidente du
parlement des présidents groupe y
compris des présidents de groupe auquel
appartiennent quelqu'un comme nick
shadow se sont émus non pas des propos
du président de la république mais du
fait que quelques eurodéputés français
ont confondu les moments et ont confondu
les endroits c'est inélégant ma nièce
est inapte au pif ont-ils et le moment
aussi je ne crois pas il a tenu un
discours très pour leur politique à
jordan bardella par exemple il ne s'est
pas laissé faire moi ce que je note
c'est que présent la république a fait
un discours sur l'europe il a un projet
européen qu'il porte qui le développe
depuis des années et des années qui
recueille l'assentiment de la plupart de
nos partenaires il a été confronté à des
interventions de députés européens
français qui étaient inappropriés
inopportune et rarement de bonne qualité
mais évidemment qu'il allait répondre y
compris pour leur dire qu'ils disent
n'importe quoi sur la construction je
reformule la question qui retarde tout
le monde c est ce qu emmanuel macron
fait sa campagne électorale sur le dos
de leurs manuels mâcon président il
préside la france qui préside le conseil
de l'union européenne nous assurer que
le mélange et je résidera
ça n'est pas un grand écart si présente
la république arrêté de présider à six
mois de la fin de mandat pour faire
campagne on lui reprochait de ne plus
travailler il préside il présidera
jusqu'à la dernière minute est ce que je
souhaite de tout mon coeur c'est qu'il
préside cinq ans de plus et brigitte sur
le fond maintenant ça c'était c'était la
forme sur le fond maintenant dans cet
agenda a chargé la présidence française
française du conseil de l'union
européenne peu de place en fait pour
cette relation très complexe post break
site paris promet surtout je cite de
veiller à préserver l'unité des états
membres et au respect par le royaume uni
de ses engagements de l'accord
commercial notamment comment en
garantissant la solidarité et l'unité de
la position européenne et qui s'est
passé sur la pêche l'a démontré c'est
une bonne réponse qui a été apportée à
une attitude nous nos partenaires
britanniques qui n'était pas un
comptable sur les questions de pêche et
heureusement les choses s'améliorent
grâce à un investissement de mes
collègues secrétaires d'état aux
affaires européennes et ministre de la
main des relations compliquées quand
même encore après il ya évidemment des
relations qui peuvent être complexes je
prends un exemple qui relève de mon
champ de compétences c'est-à-dire la
douane mais les britanniques ont un peu
tardé à établir les règles d'entrée sur
leur territoire l'europe et le marché
intérieur avait arrêté très rapidement
les règles qui s'appliquent désormais la
grande bretagne c'est ce sont les règles
qui s'appliquent aux pays tiers et aux
états tiers
la grande bretagne plus de temps et
depuis le 1er janvier ces nouvelles
règles s'appliquent et donc nous avons
des choses à gérer qui se passe bien
dans les relations techniques que nous
avons avec les britanniques dès les
premières heures de l'année 2022 nous
avions à peu près un camion sur trois
qui étaient en difficulté parce que les
nouvelles formalités n'était pas
intégrée aujourd'hui c'est moins de 10%
des camions qui rend compte des
difficultés donc nous travaillons aussi
à réguler cette relation est dit et on
va à parler d'un autre sujet qui a fait
la une cette semaine également le débat
est relancé sur l'avenir des règles
communes sont actuellement suspendues en
raison de jusque-là redoublé mis
exactement emmanuel macron à l'intention
de peser de tout son poids pour
assouplir assouplir les règles du pacte
de stabilité en europe je rappelle ce
que c'est pour nos téléspectateurs c'est
ce mécanisme qui oblige les états à voir
une rigueur budgétaire
3% du déficit budgétaire du pib et leur
dette publique à 60% du pib parce que la
france ne respecte pas est ce que la
france ne devrait de là montrer
l'exemple et est-ce que vouloir
assouplir cette règle ça n'est pas aussi
la france n'est pas seule dans ce débat
et j'y reviendrai mais la france est
aussi aujourd'hui en capacité de
participer au débat pour une raison et
une raison unique c'est que lorsqu'il
manuel macro est devenu président il est
le premier à avoir respecté cette règle
des 3% pendant trois exercices et elsa
voire même largement respectés la
question de la dette et est plus
difficile pour la france comme pour les
autres pays ce qu'eta de 60% vous
rappeler aujourd'hui fait face à un
endettement moyen en europe de 100% on
avait complètement les nouveaux voisins
oui on a des comparaisons avec nos
voisins les banques publiques les mises
et qu'on public douze de nos voisins en
existe poil en italie au portugal la
dette est plus importante en allemagne
et les moins le pays qui connaît la
dette le moins importante par rapport à
son pib 7c d'estonie qu'il ya autour de
la tête entre 15 et 20 % de dette alors
que nous nous sommes autour de 113 104
113 et 115 la grèce est plutôt autour de
180 % donc d'autres g et à la région
mais chaque pays a une situation
différente on a tous en tête ce qui se
passe en grèce avec les plans
d'ajustement et les efforts ça va mieux
la nasa ça va mieux mais avec des
finances publiques qui reste fragile
malgré les efforts incroyables que les
grecs ont dû consentir parce que je veux
dire par là c'est que nous ne sommes pas
seuls mais avec une opposition avec
l'allemagne qui revient un débat avec
l'allemagne mais il ya un point d'appui
le point d'appui c'est la communication
de la commission européenne du 19
octobre et je pense qu'on est d'accord
avec cette communication et vous la
maison que vous l'avez en tête non la
communication de la commission 19
octobre elles portent deux points le
premier c'est à dire qu'il faut des
règles qui garantissent la crédibilité
et le sérieux budgétaire qu'il faut des
règles qui encadrent les pratiques
budgétaires des états membres el dine
deuxième chose qui est très importante
pour nous et qui rejoint ce que
président de la république dit et défend
elle dit que ces règles doit être
suffisamment intelligentes et souple
pour permettre le financement des
investissements bien compris les des
investissements nécessaires la
transition écologique et la douleur
aussi le bloc des pays du sud la france
est plus haut ce n'est pas une nouveauté
ce n'est pas nous mais ce que justement
ce bloc n'est pas en train de s'élargir
encore avec un certain nombre de pays
ont signé une lettre en septembre qui
disent il faut le respect pur et simple
des traités pourquoi ne pas rester
il ya quelques états qui souhaitent le
respect pur et simple il ya aussi une
réalité la question des 3% est
intéressante aussi parce que à partir 3%
de déficit le poids de la dette publique
diminue par rapport au pib
indépendamment du fait que ce soit un
critère du pacte de stabilité ou non par
contre la réalité c'est aussi ce critère
d'endettement 1 60% qui aujourd'hui ne
répondent plus à est absolument plus à
la réalité européenne je rappelle la
réalité européenne c'est un taux
d'endettement moyen de 100 % et avec des
écarts de 1 à 10 entre les moins de 20%
de l'estonie est presque 200% de la
grèce et donc il faut aussi s'en va
personnaliser ses règles c'est olivier
dussopt obtint le ministre chargé des
comptes publics est notre invité ce
matin en face aux territoires vous dites
dans le jdd que les oppositions de
gauche se sont enfermés dans une lutte
contre les discriminations au lieu d'une
lutte contre les inégalités c'est
terrible comme constat pour vos ex amie
c'est un constat terrible aux lucides je
considère que la lutte contre les
discriminations et raid de l'adn des
progressistes des sociaux-démocrates et
et je vous êtes très clair s'agit pas de
dire que la lutte contre les
discriminations n'est pas prioritaire
par contre ce que je dis c'est que la
lutte contre les discriminations doit
s'ajouter à la lutte contre les
inégalités ne pas la remplacer et la
lutte contre les inégalités c'est avant
tout la lutte contre les causes et la
racine des inégalités c'est ce que nous
faisons par exemple quand nous des
doublons les classes de cp et de ce1
dans les réseaux d'éducation prioritaire
c'est lutter contre les inégalités
d'élite qu'elle se forme c'est-à-dire
des premières années là vous vous sentez
le plus proche duquel des huit candidats
de la gauche aujourd'hui je me sens
proche des manuels macro huit genres on
a laissé la cour lui que j'ai bossé il
faut lui on l'avait laissée pour lui que
gémir campagne mais de deux de ses nuits
tranquilles mais un succès depuis hier
mais ça change on met souvent à la
hausse qu'à la baisse mais sachez y en a
un qui caveau faveur en terme de deux
programmes et de j'aimerais pas les
montants dida et emmanuel macron va dire
qu'il ya une forme de sympathie pour le
moment mais pour ce que dit est ce que
représente fabien roussel notamment
lorsqu'ils se trouvent confrontés à des
attaques qui viennent de la gauche
qu'ils font des procès d'intention
absolument incroyable alors que lui
souhaite je ne dis pas qu'ils y arrivent
à mes yeux mais il souhaite représenter
une gauche populaire tout simplement
sympathique mais je le répète et je le
martèle je ne souhaite qu'une chose vous
en arrivez au premier tour un nom qui
est présent à un public soit candidat
quand et quand il le souhaitera et
surtout qu'il soit réélu il serait tout
pour cela françois villeroy de galhau
l'anc et le gouverneur de la banque de
france donc qui travaillent avec vous
verrez au quotidien dit la situation de
la dette doit nous inquiéter et le quoi
qu'il en coûte mise en oeuvre pour
soutenir l'économie pendant la crise
sanitaire n'est plus justifié c'est
terrible deuxième homme a faim et il dit
on regarde aux promesses de dépenses
nouvelles et de baisses d'impôts
supplémentaires pendant la moyenne aussi
nous avons mis fin en quoi qu'il en
coûte le fonds de solidarité est arrêté
avec des hommes comme sani zhaled il ya
quelques ajustements et quelques
dispositifs notamment de prise en charge
des coûts fixes pour les entreprises qui
sont l'objet de restrictions je pense
aux discothèques à l'événementiel c'est
la même chose pour les autres
dispositifs d'urgence parce que
l'économie va mieux mais vous avez
raison le dis qu'il faut revenir à une
dépense plus soutenable et parce que
revenir à une dépense plus soutenable
c'est une garantie à notre crédibilité
faire face à nos engagements je pense
que nous sommes en capacité de faire
face sans engagement et je pense que
nous le resterons à une condition c'est
que une fois sortis de la crise nous
puissions revenir comme je disais un
niveau plus soutenable de dépenses et
donc revenir progressivement un déficit
de 3% jeudi progressivement ce que nous
ne voulons pas étouffer la croissance
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
cet objectif dans le programme de
stabilité c'est qu'on a déficit à 3% ce
qui est manuel ma première réussie c'est
quoi votre ambition voudriez allez vous
faire voir ma première ambition c'est
qu'il soit réélu c'est là d'ailleurs mon
ambition s'arrête à un bis alors mon
ambition s'arrête aux 10es au 24 avril
c'est important que la relation qu est
ce qui vous intéresse autre que les
comptes vous m'avez bien dans l'émission
vous étiez pas forcément quelqu'un de
chiffres démarre je n'avais jamais
j'avais pas une formation en matière
budgétaire mais j'y prend un grand
plaisir ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
réussite de la france et où elle a
réussi de la france elle passe par la
russie quatre départements vous
intéresserez non-violent vous intéresse
à quoi si vous comptez sur moi pour
m'inscrire dans une forme de mercato
avant que les choses soient faites vous
m attendre pendant longtemps merci il ya
des étapes et la première étape c'est la
présidentielle merci olivier dussopt
merci à vous il se chargeait des comptes
publics d'avoir été notre invité merci
sylvain garcia on se retrouve
prochain avec laurent fabius le
président du conseil constitutionnel qui
fera sa rentrée politique d'en face aux
territoires au revoir à tous les
programmes continus sur tv5 monde
[Musique]